hi everyone I am theatre Buzzelli dr.
Peter Buscemi actually today we're going
to talk about fermat's last year he had
a hobby a passion for math so we go back
home and write these theorems and
conjectures Fermat's notebook add lots
of conjectures he would write down
saying oh I ever know some proof of this
but I know time to write it over the
centuries mathematicians went through
this book and found proof to all his
conjectures apart from the last theorem
the last theorem was very interesting
many people tend to the solution and
thought they found it but then somebody
proved them wrong Andrew Wiles
discovered this theorem when he was 10
years old and became obsessed with it he
worked in secret because so many people
attempted and failed he found a solution
and he presented to the public and it
was acclaimed worldwide the Queen
knighted him and it was a great success
until somebody actually found an error
in his proof he was not going to give up
that easily and it worked for another
year full time and he found the solution
and it goes like this if you have X to
the N plus y to the N equals e to the N
if n is a positive integer greater than
2 this equation is never true it looks
very simple but in mathematics proving
that something doesn't exist is always
harder than proving that something
exists this is a variety of application
in cryptography ratting encryptions and
cold and all of that you know secret
stuff and opened up a whole new world
for mathematics whole new branch
mathematics